sie sind auf dem weg zu dem was man ihr
zuhause war
günther schäfer und seine tochter hannah
das ist ihr heimatort schuld als ich
unten war eine straße die dort straße
gefahren war eine bushaltestelle also
hier ist die eine mal die andere und es
war noch zwei häuser da diesen komplett
eingestürzt viele andere häuser
unbewohnbar
einen tag vor der katastrophe wurde
hannah 19
unser haus
vielmehr was davon noch übrig ist
das vier meter sofa die stühle
das wasser hat alles mitgerissen ich
weiß noch nicht wie das alles geht oder
ob man vielleicht abreisen muss aber
diese zerstörung sie macht sprachlos
irgendwo im schutt hannas
schreibtischstuhl vor kurzem erst ihr
abi gemacht
auch meine unterlagen oder so weinsheim
ein abiturzeugnis
wie muss das sein wenn alles was man
lieb und teuer war
im matsch versinkt hanna hat etwas
gefunden
ich hatte den job gestern schon deswegen
weil ich keine schon wieder ja ich weiß
nicht wo ich sonst machen soll außer
lachen ich es tut so weh keine ahnung
wie es halt irgendwie alles weg aber sie
haben überlebt es geht weiter sagen die
beiden
die werden später erfahren auf die
schäfers ihr einsturzgefährdetes haus
überhaupt wieder betreten dürfen
die wassermassen haben auch die la
schweiz getroffen bis in den ersten
stock ihr haus direkt an der a
unbewohnbar hermann nesch alt lebte hier
mit der ganzen familie
das wasser kam mit wucht brach türen und
fenster
er floh mit frau schwiegertochter und
der zehn monate alten enkelin aufs dach
wurde gerettet
das lässt nie mehr los jetzt räumen sie
auf das ganze dorf hilft mit auch die
die nicht betroffen sind
ich habe schon einige harley aber
muslim
[Musik]
ganze teile von schuld gibt es nicht
mehr
alles wird hier nun dringend gebraucht
vor allem trinkwasser aber auch
kleiderspenden selbst fremde sind nach
schuld gekommen um zu helfen
wie tanja veit aus karlsruhe das kam mir
schon im fernsehen das im juni keine
hilfe großartig ist und dachte deswegen
ich fahre jetzt genau hierher hier in
einen ort der aussieht wie nach einem
tsunami
solche bilder kennen viele nur aus dem
fernsehen aus fernen ländern die
schicksale weit weg das ist jetzt anders
und schockt diese naturgewalt
nichts
und doch versuchen sie zu retten was
noch zu retten ist von überall kommen
freiwilliger mit baggern sie kamen von
allen seiten von aden hat zum teil leute
die dann halt eben essen vorbeigebracht
haben toilettenpapier hygieneartikel
alles was halt eben jetzt im augenblick
nur der mann war weil wir haben ja
locker sechs sieben häuser die komplett
weggespült worden sind hin fluchen und
da ist man so ja auch gerührt dazu viele
leute oder anteilen und nehmen einfach
enorm
drei tage nach der katastrophe in schuld
dürfen die schäfers ihr haus wieder
betreten
es ist einsturzgefährdet die feuerwehr
prüft was abgerissen werden muss mutter
sonja und tochter hannah können endlich
nachsehen was noch zu retten ist auf dem
fußboden schlamm in jeder ritze das war
einmal hannas schlafzimmer der blick aus
dem ersten stock apokalyptisch hier oben
immerhin alles trocken die familie
versucht seit tagen den mut nicht zu
verlieren
doch natürlich sind auch ihre kräfte
fast aufgebraucht muss ruhiger wurde lag
man nicht plötzlich
und wenn doch so ganz komisches gefühl
die schäfers hoffen so sehr dass das
glück bald wieder in ihr haus
zurückkehrt direkt gegenüber lebt die 14
jährige anna ihre beine sind voller
blutergüsse und blauer flecken ganze 40
hat sie gezählt das wasser war so viel
stärker als sie am anfang zu suchen und
zu hause zu machen dass er gar nicht
gebraucht
mir stand das wasser hüfthoch ich habe
nicht gesehen wo ich lange hier was da
schon der wurm hat sich auch grüßt ich
bin gefallen
sachen gibt's hingegen nicht gefunden es
ging einfach alles zu schnell sich daran
erinnern macht gänsehaut
gestern wäre annas letzter schultag vor
den ferien gewesen
[Musik]
die weite des meeres
das ist alles was zählt hört man hier an
jeder ecke froh am leben zu sein
nachdem das wasser sich durch den halben
ort dessen
behelfsmäßig gibt es hier nun wieder
eine straße und herum wird geballert
alle fangen
ablenken nicht nachdenken müssen was
eben hier geschehen ist für anna jetzt
noch viel klarer als zuvor
sie will später mal zur feuerwehr wenn
du mal hochwasser ist wieder etwas
anderes passiert möchte ich mit im
einsatz war
ihre sommerferien wird anna wohl hier
verbringen um ihr zuhause wieder
aufzubauen
am nächsten tag zum ersten mal sonne
es gibt nun auch eine
trinkwasseraufbereitungsanlage und ein
gerüstbauer aus der gegend baut eine
provisorische brücke um auch den letzten
teil von schuld wieder zugänglich zu
machen
privat finanziert hilfen von bund oder
land sind noch nicht da aber die
kanzlerin kommt heute nach schuld mit
ministerpräsidentin dreier
das weckt hoffnung und skepsis
vielleicht hilft es ein bisschen fokus
auf die region hätte lenken
er zeigt mir dass spenden dann brauchen
wir auch bald viele einen verloren habe
nicht alle hier freuen sich über den
besuch besonders weil er die
aufräumarbeiten behindern
hier steht alles still seit der stimme
jetzt schon die kommen hier mit den
fahrzeugen um steht essen was da alles
steht still und ja die menschen brauchen
erzeugt und die menschen wollen alte
häuser eigentlich mal weiter sauber
machen und die straßen frei räumen habe
und es gibt kritik am
katastrophenmanagement im land in den
letzten tagen haben wir ein lauter
privatleute und zivilisten hier im
einsatz
die wahlleute von
ein paar leute vom thw und so weiter es
ist ja nichts da in deutschland haben
wir im nächsten jahr an
erklärung wenn solche dinge auftreten es
ist ja alles kaputt gespart worden sich
nicht mehr laden
inzwischen sind merkel und drei jahren
getroffen machen sich ein bild der lage
gemeinsam hand in hand durchs
katastrophengebiet sie dankten den
einsatzkräften insbesondere der
feuerwehr die hier tag und nacht im
einsatz war
die menschen aus schuld sind
traumatisiert diese flut wird für die
menschen in schock hinterlassen habe ich
noch nie vergisst
die lichts bewerten sind und doch
versuchen sie das hier so sehr auch die
schäfers heute sind freunde gekommen um
gemeinsam mit ihnen alles aus dem haus
raus zu holen
vater günther schafft es immer sich ein
lächeln auf den lippen zu behalten
sie müssen sich beeilen
vor der schlamm durch das warme wetter
trocknet und bret hart wird
tochter hanna hat noch immer hoffnung
wie etwas aus ihrem alten leben
wiederzufinden wird so einfach wenn
nichts mehr steht wo es mal war
hier
für grüne steht
auch ihre kleine schwester lieber hilft
heute mit ich versuche mich jetzt so
weit es geht abzulenken weil wenn ich
darüber nachdenke dann kommen die tränen
wenn man sich ablenkt und dann kommst du
mit übernahm es muss weitergehen
irgendwie viele menschen in schuld
wollen wieder alles aufbauen für sich
und ihre familien
die schäfers und die langscheid
aber auch für gäste die hier immer
willkommen waren im kleinen schuld kommt
die ins haus ein lieber gast gibt ihm so
gut als du es hast steht noch an ihrer
flur wand ein blick nach vorn in all der
dunkelheit